okay all right here we are in overturned
uh
i have to make this a little brief got
to get to las vegas tonight no
uh john how do you think today's
mainstream media would treat abraham
lincoln if he was our current president
well i mean it's a great question look
his his media hated him he was
disrespected widely i don't think he
probably would have been elected right
now he told a lot of jokes that were
deeply inappropriate people got pissed
off at him but that was a tool right he
spoke in parables he was trying to reach
people where they were um
you know
lincoln was a huge consumer of media he
was obsessed with newspapers but he got
a lot of grief and we forget that you
know we forgot how much how many people
hated lincoln at the time he did the
difficult things and and we could still
learn a hell of a lot how tall was he
six four
in in that year that must have been
almost like being a seven footer yeah
right and he worked and he wore a stove
pipette to highlight it too he hung a
lantern on it right yeah
well that probably would have got him
elected just that don't don't they
always go for the tall guy you know
what's weird i kept finding in my book
people kept on commenting when they met
lincoln they kept saying he's the
ugliest man i ever met
they kept saying it it's terrible but
then when he started speaking and
telling stories and and connecting with
people emotionally something beautiful
happened okay
uh how has the uh successful school
board recall
bolstered the
boudin right is that how you pronounce
that yes
chaser chaser chaser boudin now that's
who we're talking about that's the d.a
in san francisco how how's the oh okay
so how has the board recall affected
that it's like that's the question i
don't know what this question in my view
it's given it's you know we just uh
passed a school board recall we recalled
three members of the board of education
in san francisco and i think it's shown
the prevailing of common sense and core
values over radicalism they were more
worried about renaming schools than
making sure that the children returned
back to in-person learning and so i
think parents and residents of san
francisco have said look
these these radical extreme ideas are
are not going to work for us anymore
what do you think about the masks with
the kids i mean is it
is it about time to chuck that
having a a five-year-old in school right
now um i would like to see them go
yeah
if i don't need them
kids i mean kids are the least
least vulnerable and i i mean to make
these little children into into howie
mandels is what you're doing
no it's true you're creating a
generation of howie mandels of little
germ paranoid munchkins it's just it's
it's it's like it is it is it's so ridic
it's it's been like it's it's a huge
chunk of their lives i mean we've got
young kids i mean it's especially when
they're young i mean that's the first
thing they remember and it's going to
get imprinted on them and it's just i
mean kids are gross to begin with you
got to let them be gross
what right maybe they think and they're
not on germs they're not they need also
to get germs in their body
of course there are ones you can't get
in your mind yeah you know what yeah i
mean that's true what are the reasons
the whole vaccine is how do you get
healthy is you live in the world with
the yeah you can't live in the world by
getting rid of all germs of course
avoiding them of course
we've been taking the vaccine debates
are so incredibly dumb because we've
been doing mandatory vaccines for public
school kids forever for polio this is
not any different it's just what we need
to deal with well it could be different
if the if they are less vulnerable to it
that kills are vulnerable to polio
they're not that vulnerable to this one
that's been true from the beginning of
course anybody can get anything at any
time that's possible but we always have
to go by the numbers
okay
moving on because i got to leave
uh no katrina you mentioned on twitter
that you were interned for p.j iraq pj
o'rourke one of my faves uh
died this week
so um frequent guest on this show
[Applause]
what's one of your most favorite
memories i hope you have great
do have great memories
i was me too ten times no no i do well
no not
but no no i mean i uh was an intern at
the
national lampoon and they were nice he
was great and we did the high school
yearbook together and then we did a mock
you'll like this we did a mock issue of
high times which is buried somewhere i
want to find that but he thought it was
a mock issue he did a very important
role
[Applause]
but he was a wonderful he was great he
was great p.j.r
i mean i've said this many times
publicly on this show and anywhere else
to anybody who will listen uh pj does
not get the credit he deserves for
establishing an entire brand of humor it
was more than just what he did when he
edited that national lampoon the
national lampoon became saturday night
live it did okay there's a whole
way of doing comedy that really sprung
from guys like pj o'rourke and
prominently pj eric he was one of my
faves anyway thank you folks thank you
folks
you